[Music]
hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about the porn so Mel Sanjay often
referred to as the red woman in the
final season of Game of Thrones no
Sanjay briefly appeared in season 7 to
bring guys and fire John and Danny
together then an episode later she
disappeared not to be seen ever since
but before she left the red priestess
had a conversation with various which
hinted at where she's going and why
Melisandre explained that she will live
forever Lana shortly but stated that she
will return to Westeros one day for like
various she's fated to die there now
before we get into the question why she
is going to volantis let me just remind
you that at the end of season 6 Musashi
was upset at Jon exiled her from the
north now that the great work in the
night King is upon them explaining to
Jon that he knows she can help him in
that war so at the end of season 6
Melisandre is upset that she cannot be
with him at Winterfell but now she goes
to Essos well frank conversation with
various we know that she's obviously
planning on returning from volantis and
i'm guessing it'll be to bring a small
army back with her as a monster and
Melisandre will not be coming back
empty-handed so the only reason she's
even going to a so sisterly the Lord of
Light sacred soldiers also known as the
fire hand and bring them to Westeros
basically just like Cersei male Sanjay
will bring some warriors from Essos
but Alex Cersei Mills Sanjay plans to
use them against the night king the
fiery can contains that thousand
soldiers never more and never less each
of these soldiers is a slave of [ __ ]
they wear ornate armor or their orange
robes and veiled spirit point shaped as
rising flames as per custom of Lainey's
these slaves have flames tattooed across
their cheeks the fiery hand is a group
of warriors which guard the red temple
of rather in the free city of Atlantis
which happens to be the exact location
and Sun she's headed to in the beginning
of season 7 you'll remember that Tyrion
pass through Elena's in season 5 and got
an up-close look at red priestess
preaching to a group of slaves about the
coming of Danny he did not see there a
temple or the fiery hand but if the show
follows the books they were not far so
we know that the followers of the Lord
of Light Stan
Danny we got another indication of that
vendor in season six Darian summoned the
High Priestess of the red temple of a
man named Kim Mara to help shore up
support for the Jerome queen among the
common people
kin Mara was all in on that idea that
Danny was the one who was promised
saying that she had been sent to lead
people against the darkness in this more
and in a great were still to come she
needed no convincing Melisandre is just
a red priestess in the religion of
[ __ ] the Lord of Light and therefore
she is not powerful enough to rally the
fire Han and bring into Westeros on her
own the fiery hands her directly to the
high priest of [ __ ] and carrier the
high priests will unquestioningly
however we already made this high priest
kumara a me know that she sees Danny as
the one who was promised kin Mara the
flame of truth fight wisdom and first
servant of the Lord of Light the High
Priestess of the temple of Elena this is
one of the highest ranking of rattler
clerics since she firmly believes the
danger gariands the prince that was
promised it's very likely that when el
Sanja shows up at Elena's senses to
clean Mara that the time has come it's
likely that quinoa reveal order to fire
him to go with no Sanjit Westeros to
help Danny the one they see as the one
who's promised the fee denied King Plus
as followers of rel are the fiery Cain
might possess magical capabilities
similar to those valid by the most
popular red priest of the Lord of Light
investors Thoris Amir including flaming
swords which could come in handy against
the naggings white army especially since
her Seville not be sending any Lannister
troops into the fight Taurus Samir was a
red priest of the Lord of Light and the
noted warrior born in the free city of
Meereen Essos who was tasked by the high
priest to turn future King Robert
Baratheon away from the seven and
convert him to the Lord of Light Taurus
beside the ability of pyrokinesis which
is the ability to ignite his sword blade
in flames by simply running his hand
over it
Thoris also had the ability to call a
man back from dead by laying his hands
on their marriage citing prayers to the
Lord white if each of those 1000
warriors of the fire had possessed those
same abilities they would be worth more
than in the other army and we thought
that that would be a huge help for John
and Danny
in conclusion Mel Sanchez headed to
Helena's home to one of the largest red
temples in the religion of [ __ ] and
also happens to be working Mara the red
priestess we met in seasons
is from if you recall King Mohammed
Tyrion and told him she believed that
Danny is the princess that was promised
she also agreed to convince her people
to follow Danny which is a great news
because she's kind of a big deal well
she's from her full title High Priestess
of the temple of Alanis the flame of
truth the light of wisdom and first
servant of the Lord of Light considering
they're both going to converge Himalayas
and they're both part of the same crew
and they both believe in Danny's cause
it's safe to assume else and Janki
Marvel team-up kin Mara's Vasavi Tyrion
definitely felt a little random at the
time but if the show brings her
character back in season a to help Danny
defeat our foes especially since we know
Cersei intends to enlist the help of the
gun company a cell sword army also based
in Essos Melisandre could help tie
things up quite nicely for Danny before
she fulfills her own prophecy and comes
back to die masters I believe most and
she will not be coming back empty-handed
and the only army she could bring with
her would be the fiery hand the Lord of
Light sacred soldiers so most times
you'll probably show up in an FLV new
army just before denying attacks which
is not coming as a huge surprise knowing
the sheer self declared that she would
not stay away permanently mulaney's and
would eventually return to face rent
this led the possibility of return for
Mills Sanji possible and HBO recently
appeared to confirm it HBO posted the
cast for the first episode of season 8
on its website with when Holden's name
an actress who plays no Sanjay included
it did not take long for HBO to remove
the information from its website as a
show's fans around the world caught on
to the groundbreaking spoiler but
nonetheless many people saw it and it's
a confirmed spoiler I know Mel sanjay
will not be a Westeros in episode 1
we'll probably see her arriving in
volantis and having meeting with Kamara
in my opinion most on she will arrive at
Winterfell in the same episode does nut
King does in episode 3 how I see the
fiery hand arriving a minor fellow be
without man Sandra or at least without
her at first glance Melisandre is exiled
from the north but all she wants is to
help so the best fighter sure that would
be with her showing up in ur true form
and not making any tension
the fiery hand is Darren Kumar's orders
that's it as you all know after that was
come for an email Sanj about burning of
Shirin mal Sanjay is made to live in
Chelsea from me
never to return or she'll be hanging by
John Snow that was also told her that if
she is ever to cross paths with him he
will execute her himself almost and she
wants to do is help so it would not make
sense for her to show up in her fell as
the head of this one thousand strong
army of the Lord of Light she would risk
it again he hanged or once again made
leave and since the North doesn't need
any tension now that the night King is
arriving at their homes nostalgia
probably will not look for some it will
probably remain as recover by undercover
I mean in her true form that no
character has ever seen by this theorem
else and she will take over her necklace
along with her beauty and youth with it
and will reveal her true form which is a
frail old woman in order to stay by John
Snow as the theory goes Melisandre
energy o form will return to the north
Winterfell with the arrival of the fiery
hand but no one will notice her since no
one actually knows how she really looks
like this female Sanjay will save John
for more tension helped John during the
Battle of Winterfell and even possibly
resurrect some of the main characters
who are going to get killed but in that
king in his arm
however male Sanjay will eventually have
to sooner or later will her true
identity and that's when your prophesied
death will probably take place Musashi
prophesied that she would die in
Westeros but she also prophesied that
she would meet again with an assassin
Arya Stark and many thing that's come
out Sanja story blent going into the
final season one of the top predictions
we all have is arya most likely having
an encounter with Melisandre
fulfilling nostalgia's prophecy that she
told her I see a darkness in you and in
the darkness eyes staring back at me
brown eyes blue eyes green eyes eyes
that you'll shut forever we'll meet
again
Arya did shut all desires the only me
anything of the prophesied country is
not such a meeting Ari again in my
opinion business Sanjay's prophecy will
definitely come true the question is how
is the meeting going to end most are
just firmly mulaney's but as she said it
herself shall return one last time
because she has to die masterís in my
opinion she will come back with her own
army and in her true form but as I
already mentioned she will sooner or
later revealed that it's her be no Marya
and we know that she's dedicated to
decreasing the names on a kill list and
we also know that Melisandre is on that
list because she tried to kill Kenji if
Arya is not destined to
Sanjay then I can see their union taking
place in the first episodes of season 8
bottarga eater kill him in sanjay after
which the Lord of Light would bring her
back to life since she's got many things
yet to do as she said herself Oh John
normal Sanjay could somehow manage to
come in sorry that she's saved John's
life which will bring her arias
absolution one way or another the Rebs
women role in season 8 will be of a huge
importance and her story will be very
interesting
I'm sure militant she will not be coming
back empty-handed and I hope it's the
fiery hand she brings with her please
let me know your thoughts about all of
this in the comment section down below
do you think male Sanjay will return to
Westeros with some kind of a force army
and why do you think she is even going
to Alanis when she returns to expect
from her to return in her true form and
that they avoid being executed and
making more tension in the north or do
you think Mel Sanjay will appear in her
most usual form also do you think also
geometer end when the prophesied opinion
between her and arya takes place or do
you have something else in mind let me
know and as always I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see in the next one peace